was 14 I had 400 sex partners by force
and I was drugged at 16 I was living in
East LA and a trailer by first in Soto
male prostitute on Santa Monica
Boulevard and at 18 I was homeless in
Balboa Park in San Diego doing anything
and everything to get my next hit of
dope so very few people talked about the
sex trade sexual abuse and the many
repercussions that come from that in our
communities and what would you recommend
to somebody like me who live that life
who did go to Harvard after that who did
go to Berkley who had that mother that
stood by me no matter what to get that
story out so I keep being told tell your
story tell your story and I'm not gonna
let the opportunity pass having Jorge
Ramos in front of me to say how do you
how do you address these issues of the
drug trade sex trade and the impact
that's having on our youth and someone
like me who is just new to government
feels that frustration when I feel I had
more impact in the private sector you
have the courage that I don't have and
and what you just did right now that's
so full of courage you ganas and I think
you know much more about that than I do
but I think what's so important is that
you have the courage to tell that story
to everyone here and you can tell that
same story in many different ways you
write a book you go on social media if
you start the conversation with other
people that's precisely what we need to
hear I'm always frustrated with former
presidents I talked to president Fox and
Brazilian sorry Gaby dia and they always
I study we call their own
well it's good but but what's so
interesting is the former presidents you
always say oh yes legalize drugs but
when they are in power they don't have
the course to do them so I I cannot
pretend that I know exactly what you
should do but I think what you just did
right now that's precisely what you
should do tell your story don't be
afraid tell your story you just did
[Music]
congratulations Jorge thank you for
being here Mexican Mauricio 'try I have
I would like to ask you to input about
two topics one of them is the met the
independent can candidacies in Mexico
how are they going to to to develop and
the and the impact for Latins here in in
the States and the other one is what do
you think about the double citizenship a
Latin a Latino citizenship and the
American citizenship of one person being
in Mexico how is he being looked by the
people I can I have two passports I can
vote here in the United States and I can
board in Mexico and I think it's fine
because I'm from both countries actually
from both countries that that's what
defines me right now and and that could
be criticized and I'm always criticized
here in the United States and in Mexico
I'm always criticized the fact is that
I'm for both countries I cannot change
them and if I am if I'm having an
influence in both countries why
shouldn't I vote in both countries
at the same time those in need diminish
your power if you are in if you want to
pursue something in the government arena
well I don't think you can I don't think
you can run right in Mexico if you have
double yeah yeah there are many
different ways of doing that so if you
want to run us an independent Mexico
obviously you have to give up one of the
one of the citizenships and the
independent candidacy I think is
beautiful Mexicans are as fed up as
Americans with with the establishment
and then just imagine having the
possibility of having an independent
candidate in Mexico it would be
fantastic then we'll be the problems but
but as candidates
you'll be I'm all for it absolutely all
for it Jorge Castaneda for for that four
years and he was denied and now he's he
and many others will have the chance to
run who wants a PRI or pan or PRD in
Mexico they we won't change right so so
I'm all for it all for it
thank you thank you
so you can see some of you were not my
name is Giovanni Escovedo and I am
dreamer
there are other six dreamers that just
like me take the challenge to come to DC
and become a congressional interns I
think we've taken that stand to
represent our community but what can the
media and our community do to stand with
us and possibly change the future not
only of dreamers but of our parents how
old were you when you got here
excuse me how old were you when you got
to this 15 15 and I think you're already
changing the conversation you don't the
look the tactics that you've used and I
say us as a dreamer the in-your-face
tactics that you've had nobody nobody
else has used that when you go to the
offices of Senators and members of
Congress and you tell them your story
that changed everything when you decided
to go to the White House and tell the
president that changed absolutely
everything so it is not a matter of the
dreamers have a strength that immigrant
community didn't have in the past the
traditional Hispanic leaders look at you
in despair saying what are these still
boys doing know
did you change in the conversation so
just don't be afraid just keep on saying
what you think and I think that's that's
the most important thing I for many many
many years we were waiting for another
Cesar Chavez and Cesar Chavez in 1984 he
said in a speech in California he says I
I've seen the future and the future is
ours well he was talking about you know
that that's the future not only in the
numbers or in the way we can change the
conversation and you are changing the
conversation so I think it is the other
way around you just don't realize that
but it is the politicians looking at
what you are doing
the other way around so thank you thank
you sorry I interrupted before but I to
here in oxymoron I'm a Guatemalan
feminist and that's the reason why I'm
standing here I have a dual citizenship
as well so even though I was born here I
am as watermelon as you can believe and
I don't want to die without seeing a
female president in either other of my
country and I read an article last night
before I went to sleep because I
continuously I'm attacked on I'm voting
for Hillary Clinton because I'm voting
for Hillary I do not feel the Bern I'm
sorry and they attack me by saying I'm
voting for her because she's a woman you
know what maybe I am so I read an
article last night and it says if you
were to twist around the plot if Hillary
did not have the Ivy League if she were
not former first lady if she had not
ever been in the White House
chances are she wouldn't have the
momentum that Bernie does so if Bernie
were Bernadette Bernie would not be seen
near you or nobody will be burning
feeling the Bernadette Bern you know so
what's your stand on that I know that
you are harsh so sometimes we're
different on things there but I want to
hear a good standpoint on Hillary
Clinton yeah and I'm not going to talk
about that because I think my job for
instance I think I can be tough on both
Republicans and Democrats many people
thought that we couldn't do that and
I've been really tough on Trump I've
been really tough on Marco Rubio and Ted
Cruz for turning their backs on the
immigrants who came after their parents
and I think last debate with the
Democrats I think I was tough enough
with the Sanders and with Hillary
Clinton and
that's my job but but something
important I think is that as a
journalist I think I can be tough and
independent but I cannot be partisan if
I work here and tell you I'm for one
party or the other you just wouldn't
trust me so do you think that if the
plots were the other way around
Bernadette would be standing where she
is right now tell me now thank you thank
you you know we have a few minutes but I
would like to hear all of you so why
don't we hear all of you and then I'll
stay a few more well another I were to
sign your books I just don't want you to
be here forever
so go ahead short questions okay let's
do it okay let's play again during the
debate now you feel the you see you see
how difficult it is during the debate
the candidates agree on certain rules
and they have to give an answer in 30
seconds sometimes they have a minute but
if they have to respond they have to do
in 30 seconds so this is my challenge
for each one of you okay you have 30
seconds for the question or a comment
whatever you want and I won't say
anything until the end but you have 30
seconds ready okay go ahead
I'm seeing the number of 34 Oh
my name is Ramirez had me in town from
Kansas I go to the University of Kansas
entering here and my question was have
you ever thought about running for
office in the past that it ever crossed
your mind
are we ever gonna see a president Elam
was in me he questioned other the
Florida
a journalist I think I better use my
influence as a journalist but I at some
point yes I did consider going back to
Mexico that's what I I went to grad
school not anymore
I'm 57 already it's another generation
it's your turn next 30 seconds put in
the order everyone's just yeah just
brief comment I want to say thank you
for your staying truthful in the
election and providing one of the most
unbiased moderations I've ever seen in
the election so far so congratulations
and I really appreciate that and keeping
keeping us honest but for a question a
lot of us are rebels here a lot of us
are dreamers a lot of us are outspoken a
lot of hopefuls here but sometimes along
the way we stumble right and we fall
down and what guidance can you provide
or what what light can shed on those
that fall you know and then though we
don't want to get back up sometimes
because especially as minorities right
those Falls are really hard just follow
the example of the dreamers no they were
really afraid of in even being deported
and look what they did no they changed
the conversation it's okay to be afraid
you just have to conquer them if you can
conquer that you'll be impossible
30 seconds way tempering in the [ __ ] on
Casa de Vera Cruz
so I'm actually from the most dangerous
stage for journalists in Mexico so
besides I guess condemning the apps that
is habit that are happening you more
than anyone else know how much influence
the US government has in Mexico polity
in Mexican politics and Max is Mexico's
policy so what should the US government
do about the atrocities that are
happening to journalists in Mexico
I wish the US government would speak
much more about that but besides
contaminate look any policy that you
think that should be honest yeah I think
it is
Mexicans who would have to deal with
that directly I mean if if we if there
was the US government directing on what
to do with human rights violation in
Mexico the way Mexicans are they
wouldn't respond positively
I think Mexicans are changed in Mexico
from within
and that's what we have to do what's
happening with another Duarte Maricruz
it's completely unacceptable and
Mexicans are realizing that gracias
Jorge cannot miss Adriana's a Mexico
metal heron muita so it's been 15 years
since I haven't gone back I'm going back
on Thursday Jamaica miss para Jorge
first time in 15 years
Kumiko más para que podemos hacer de
este lado pay sprayed on extra gente e
bali la Penna ser algo que si Eureka
Valley la Penna sir mucho y ya lo estas
haciendo aqui aqui podemos decir cosas
en mexico no podemos decir no Yelich
okay desperado decir lo aqui es muy
importante y cuando vias cake when sur
la historia sia
suerte we're not just recording I'm
William Gomez I'm the college chapter
leaders or the college chapter
coordinator for define American and
define American seeks to change the
conversation around immigration and and
we recently launched our college
chapters Network and so I wanted to ask
you and this is why I'm recording so
that I can show our chapter leaders
later on thorny yeah Jose Antonio Vargas
is our founder how can our chapter
leaders are young chapter leaders in
colleges around the country change the
conversation on their campus and bring
in folks who are maybe fellow students
who are reluctant to join the
conversation I don't know - you tell me
what are you doing well define American
is built around telling our stories
having folks who are undocumented come
out and tell their stories like myself
am a dreamer from argentina and the
stories right that's right and allies as
well but how do we how do we through
those stories bring allies in the folks
that we really need so that we're not
preaching to the choir I think what
you're doing is Prasad I I want to hear
your stories all over the place for in
the last debate we did something that
for us seemed really simple we brought
mother with five kids when was the last
time that you've seen an undocumented
immigrant on national TV in mainstream
TV that's the kind of stories that we
need to hear more for us it's normal
that was not normal for many people and
nothing what you want wasn't when you
are doing that is wonderful thank you
very much my resume you know I I want to
hear you instead of me giving you answer
so I'm not gonna respond any more but I
want to hear you okay
thirty seconds each and then we'll have
like another 15 minutes would that be
okay yes all right
well I actually have a couple of
questions there are great questions I
promise okay you have 30 seconds so like
I'm from Puebla Mexico I studied at even
America as well and I was wondering what
was your greatest challenge that you had
and how do you overcome it how do you
decide to move forward instead of
backwards and what would you say to
emerging leaders especially female
leaders Hispanic leaders in in the
country if you have any advice yeah for
me the most difficult thing was to
decide to to be an immigrant I just
didn't want to be an immigrant I was
poor so I think the most difficult thing
for me was to come to the United States
I was 24 I don't know what was I
thinking but I gave up everything and
came back I think that was that was the
most difficult decision for me go ahead
and yeah bye sorry
we'll talk later okay
I just wanted to thank you and when you
were talking about the objectivism in
journalism that's something that really
resonates with me as someone who's
really passionate about human rights
issues because I think a lot of
journalists don't take a stand like you
do so I really appreciate it but I had a
question in terms of the journalism
narrative around Trump
how do journalists respect him as a
candidate because he is a candidate and
that does as idiotic as he is it does
deserve a similar voters respect but not
legitimize his hate speech in the
violence he's continuing to like message
yeah I just wish they it would be
tougher on him I mean he's been getting
softballs for way too long I think we
have we got to change them thank you hi
my name is Melina I'm from Puerto Rico
not Mexico but I love Mexico my question
is given the financial crisis that my
island is going through and my heart's
bleeding so and our background of so
much political fanaticism that there's
no real clarity on to how we got here
and what we can do who would you
interview and what would you ask to get
some clarity and what's really going on
and how we can help to fix it what oh
Rico yes I don't know we're asking the
candidates but honestly I think the
answer has to be done by Puerto Ricans
know it I find it strange that we're
asking the u.s. what to do in Puerto
Rico it's it's unthinkable in other
countries and in many ways I think of
Puerto Rico as as an independent nation
in many many ways but that's my point of
view thank you
hi Jorge I work at the Mexican Embassy
here in DC thanks for being here during
your speech you talk for example of how
whites in 2055 are gonna be a minority
in the US and people cheered then you
talked about tortillas being sold more
than bagels and people cheered and catch
more than thousand people cheered don't
you think that we have to be very
careful not to sound more superior and
not to compare things and not to to seem
to be saying that whites are inherently
not that good like cheering for those
things sounds as discriminatory as many
things that many whites do in this
country so I think we have to be very
very careful with the way we portray
things and the way we celebrate certain
things
I have a completely different point of
view I think prescient I think I think
president Pena Nieto has done a terrible
job responded to Donald Trump that
president Pena Nieto took 241 days to
respond to Donald Trump that's not the
way to do it recommends even español
para que lo girl in Mexico el Presidente
Mexico's a turbo dose into's Walenta und
Sen responder adore Antrim es annoyed la
manera de ser un leader y know me parece
que Haga char la cabeza say una forma
respond Ernie Eskander se hace que
okay ii make miko knowledge boost like
yesterday I wasn't I wasn't talking
politics I was talking more about
society that wants to create a mixed
society where there Asians were there
african-americans or there are gonna be
a lot of Latinos and you want to bring
these societies together not make one
better than the other I don't think
we're making one better than the other
I'm just recognizing the growth and the
changes and the trends which is very
community okay thank you
good evening Jorge you devote you
dedicated your 2004 book to the first
Latino president who you said at the
time had already been born and that's
the fact that I still remember to this
day because that's the line that
inspired me to go into public policy I
want to ask a lot Pino has not yet made
it to the general election what do you
see that day looking like and what is
that going to mean for the Latino
community when a president is elected
probably we had a we had the wrong idea
about the first Hispanic president we
thought he was gonna be a Democrat and
now we realize it you might be you might
be a Republican so in that way I think
that mcquarrie party has to do much more
I mean where's the Latino candidate from
the Democratic Party where's the Asian
candidate from the Democratic Party the
african-american candidate from the
Democratic Party in that way Republicans
they're doing something right in that
sense anyway but we had again the idea
that it was going to be a Democrat now
it seems that Marco Rubio and Ted Cruz
if not this election they might have a
better chance in the next election so
we'll see hello my name is Diego I'm
from Guatemala kind of tied up that
question there's an argument among
political scientists that say that the
Latino community is in a tough spot
because AIDS it's a spot where the
Republican Party has kind of abandoned
the Latino apology policy choices but
the Democrats have also don't have to
worry about the Latino policy choices
because they've already insured their
vote so what do you think about that
what do you think the Latino community
can do to make sure that their policy
choices are not only promises
exactly they can take us for granted
think george w bush 44% of the Hispanic
vote at that point remember
2004 Republicans thought that they would
split the Hispanic vote and then of
course they they made many many mistakes
especially on immigration but I think
Democrats would make a huge mistake if
they take the Hispanic vote for granted
when it comes to values when it comes to
the importance of family the importance
of religion the suspicion of big
government I think many Latinos feel
closer to the Republican Party than to
the Democratic Party if they don't take
that into consideration Democrats are
here for a surprise thank thank you when
I started this on my name is Elizabeth
and I'm a Mexican American born from
immigrant parents and I'm actually
pretty nervous ending up here because
I've been watching you since I was maybe
like you would come on at 6 o'clock and
I would go to my room because I wouldn't
want to watch the news at that point
right but you know I started seeing you
around like your books and everything
that's when I started thinking about my
Mexican identity and your Mexican and
Europe you know you're always
identifying as an immigrant and so being
born here and my parents being Mexican
I've had to kind of mesh those two
things together but I've always seen you
as a reporter not an activist and to me
that's how I just grew up knowing it was
a journalist so in you identifying as an
immigrant in the u.s. a lot of the
reporting that you do is because you're
influenced on this culture like does
this culture being the mixture of like
American and Mexican influence your
reporting that you do when you do stuff
in Mexico absolutely everything I mean
it would be Who I am affects everything
that I do in the fact that I'm an
immigrant it means that I'm reporting
about immigrants in the United States
and out about Tanzania and not about
South Africa do you think that still
connects to the public that you're
reporting to though being in Mexico and
them not really knowing or being
immersed in all our culture here in the
US you know Sandra Cisneros the
wonderful writer she told me I had the
opportunity to talk to
and then she said that until she
realized that she had a specific point
of view and that she was different from
the others that's when she found her
voice and I I think I found my boys when
I accepted completely that I am Who I am
and I'm an immigrant and that changes
everything that I do it's a different
story than yours and Sandra has a
different story but when Sandra Cisneros
recognized that she was who she was she
wrote the house of mango street and now
she's in Mexico do you know she's living
in Mexico right now San Miguel and she's
looking for her house and and I'm
looking for my house too and when you're
an immigrant you're always looking for
your house for a home a place to call
home and that therefore your question is
beautiful because I cannot be anyone
else I can't compete with under some
Hooper or I can't compete with CBS News
for NBC News because I'm not them so my
only value is to recognize Who I am in
Sandra Cisneros a place Eliana so either
Venezuela I moved to Texas when I was 10
years old and I got really involved in
politics against my parents wishes and I
got really involved in getting a Tina
bow out in Texas in the most
conservative town of Texas look like and
it was it was a frustrating experience
to talk to Latinos who constantly told
me I was wasting my time how do you
channel that anger or that frustration
that you might get insulted from doing
your work or something you feel
passionate about do things do things no
and that's exactly what you're doing now
put that anger that frustration into
something and it works beautifully you
see how you you're already starting
changing things right registers and
Bodines that's doing things right
something you can touch you do something
that you can touch it that's a beauty of
of writers and sculptures and artists
that he can actually touch there
they can touch their frustration they
can touch their enthusiasm no do
something that you can actually touch
and it changes everything
thank you and thank you for covering
Vanessa thank you how are we doing on
time five more minutes can you do then
I'll stay - right - just write some book
out of raphson's stuff and pictures
right you want selfies I don't know how
we're gonna do with it selfies okay so
if weif five more minutes
so it would be like three and three
okay movin and nachos hurry estoy
hablando de los novios combien de poder
con assert a el dia de Oh mi nombre
sanic are mi yeah Gomez soy de Mexico
trabajo en la ciudad de DC en servicio
sociales trabajo con bastante jóvenes
que vienen de refugee ADO's say mucho
spices desde Mexico Costa Rica
Afghanistan de varios lagares y una de
las cosas que mi me gusta proyectarte
ellos es que nunca tengan miedo de ser
immigrant a scene on Katanga miedo de
dead record a dil-don't a bien any
koalas on surah he says es algo que tu
siempre me proyecta Samia cuando desde
pequeña Tamira men la televisión de mis
Papa's en una visión
y el dia de tengo el placer de estar
aqui contigo y pregant art a simple
meant a koala sido la persona que mas
orgullo cestas de poder ver entrevista
doe es que nunca nunca cabin siendo
politico's no y la verga reseed o como
es cuando la la laaaa exotic on my mama
yo bro que eso acaba haciendo lo que me
Marco mucho más que cualquier otra
persona
pero pero en trail prio DS mo por ESO
por que quería conocer a la gente que
cambia el mundo y por hem blow es un
privilegio no Sara Sandra Sotomayor see
a Sonia Sotomayor
Sandra Cisneros he says if a cualquier
present present a barack obama creo que
una inspiration enorme para para muchos
Hoeven is Latinos aqui no you're okay yo
que estas cosas son model uses interest
goose commercial pop aqui hablar conmigo
creo que no oh hi Jorge my name is
Valerie I'm a journalism student at
Georgetown University and I have a
question about journalism in general
you've been very open about a post and
Donald Trump but in journalism school
they teach you that we have to be
impartial but I'm originally from
Venezuela
I'm from it's very difficult to stay
objective with the situation that is
happening in my country so my question
is when does the journalist end and and
the person begins well I would put it in
a different way I think maybe that maybe
the question should be I think this way
when as a journalist you have to take a
stand because if you're reporting about
a crash or a fire if five people that
you said five people if it's red is red
and you you do but if you do the basic I
completely agree with the basics of
journalism the objectivity and that you
have to be neutral you're not to be
partisan but then sometimes you have to
take a stand when it comes again as I
said it when it comes to racism
discrimination corruption public lies
dictatorship human rights you have to
take a stand
did you see spotlight yes okay you
remember what happened with Watergate
here reporters took a stand in spotlight
you see reporters taking a stand against
the Catholic Church with the victims
they took a stand at some point they
just can't be neutral they can say oh
look at this priest he abuse a child
let's give him exactly the same time as
as the victims no they took a stand and
I think as it's happening right now in
Venezuela is somebody is abusing human
rights beauty nouns are as a reporter
that's your job as a reporter so I agree
with the basics in other words we have
to report it
what we see but what if you don't take a
stand nothing happens the best examples
of great journalism that we have in the
United States it were our morale against
John McCarthy
Walter Cronkite during the Vietnam War
under some Cooper after Katrina
spotlight that's the best of journalism
when you take a stand
not all the time a few times but if you
don't take a stand you don't you're not
doing your job
I think I think we have a time for two
more questions
and then the rest I know who's next
go ahead mr. Thomas my name is Mary Lynn
boo I actually worked for Jim Palladino
he's very very dear to the Washington
Post I'm a dreamer been here for 16
years I was soon to be undocumented
unless we blew this in this election my
my one topic that nobody's talking about
it means very heartbreaking it very
frustrating is you know we're talking
about a lot of millions of immigrants
that being deported back to the country
my native country Honduras you have in
Salvador Guatemala and many of us even a
lot of journalists as well you know
we're all blaming the the US you know
we're fighting against the Obama or
whoever it seemed as kicking all these
people but then again we're not being
upset we're not being frustrated with
the government you know I don't do that
it's the president of unto us the
president of it Salvador
so my question my two question says how
the Latinos that are here how can we
advocate from from South Sunil's how can
we protect and fight for those people
that are being because a lot of these
children you know they go back and the
majority of them are dying my yogi of
these teenagers are going back to gang
members so it's very heartbreaking that
we're not protecting them from our and
and the other thing is you know we talk
about this is a white privilege country
but you know I wasn't born here but I
see that a lot of Latinos that are born
here or that I become residents become
United they become citizens they don't
realize the great privilege privilege
that they have in this country and it
frustrates me and it very aggravates me
a lot that they're not fighting
the people and they don't necessarily
have to have a family member and you
know and may he go and onto the sore in
Lyon America they're not fighting for
those people so how as you as an
activist as a journalist what what can
you tell to the Latinos here pretty much
how can I say in Spanish inject our it's
up assume para que esta pelea por la
people a persona guess nine Latin
America cuz the Latinos in here are
taking really taking for granted that
there's people in our countries that
they're dying and nobody cares so what
do you have to say to them I think what
you're doing is speak up speak up when
when Eric garner was killed by the New
York Police Spike Lee decided to speak
up he did it he didn't have to do it but
he did it and then when you see
something happening in Honduras right
hear your voice you have no idea of how
important is for the Latin American
governments what we are saying here
about them in just in social media well
but you have your voice here and what
you're saying right here see Spanish is
broadcasting can just imagine the impact
that that could have in Honduras yeah
thank you
that's your voice como se most severe
[Music]
widowed welcome water Fujiyama grant
through the likes on young sovietic a
friend al English aqui was posted up on
Yahoo and reenter sarah guard Oh God in
Latin America me gusta has opened a link
Lassiter's discreet aureole Alecto de e
me gusta el que usted es su mismo si
Trent años el mismo Jorge Ramos que
Canseco's como scripter como period ista
como persona cassava scribble Collison
Alexian dismiss importantes gusto en de
otra vez this
be released hey Pablo yo creo que o
Allah o Veera tenido mess pareo deist
ascend mexico que a velar an sin miedo
suger acido nouvelle Rado Ventanas yo
espero que que sólo de silva or Adela
muchos otros
Matar de muchos anos an aprender mucho
mucho Mucho thing hi Jorge
my name is Maria Jose I'm originally
from San Pedro salon do does and my
question to you is what do you think the
Honduran government should do to
decrease the amount of violence and
murders happening in the country right
now and what is your opinion about the
amount of high-ranking politics
politicians that got away with the
social health insurance scam let me just
it's a long answer but but but in terms
of Honduras I think that's the real
crisis right now yeah I mean I agree in
Honduras what the - all other how do you
stop the violence now we really don't
know exactly how to do that I'm not even
gonna pretend to to know right now
everybody everybody's trying different
ideas but I think everything the drug
trade is affecting everything the war on
drugs hasn't worked at all so maybe
that's the first place to start today
we're talking about a decades-long
problem he's not going to stop soon but
I would start with the war on drugs it
isn't working it isn't working ok thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Kobi Nikki the MU Chiquita take care oh
I'd rather say poor delicate ooh Libra -
mama porque me acuerdo con otra vez que
nos vemos era una battacor la liga de su
de no latino-americans Unidos ET pour
cela que mi mamá y tu eres su Vida low
so para el acuerdo maximo e para muchos
de nosotros también kb mimosa key
there's a muy pequeño cerdo spices my
birthday pico bonito louis a no lo que
estas haciendo rachana poor Azmi grandes
see you putting the candidates on the
spot there as you have been I just think
it's it's great that you keep doing that
and that you keep reminding them that
they can't just you know what I look
caller where they have to respond to you
so
I just really want to commend you for
you know standing up in front of that
old trunk
and making sure that your voice was
heard and now everyone knows that they
could not take your Hispanic vote for
granted they cannot take us for granted
and they do have to respond back to your
question I think I hope something thank
you so much for six okay three minutes
30 seconds each
okay I gotta do a quick order so that
second switch really very rapid when I
am Oh Luis Aguilar so yes just comment
so you dream er as he saw a lobbyist in
Virginia and Tennessee on undocumented
obvious Y Tenedos preguntas porque no
preguntamos sobre Berta Caceres and en
el anele anele anele devotee
y por que esperamos a crear una cultura
civic ax and react Co Nidal trampy
porque no creo salgo a largo plazo en
esto la razón de vino sub repent o Berta
Caceres no yet no excuses Horace my name
is Veronica and I am from Ukraine and I
am now pretty good how it's going to
force and back I didn't have my son in
Ukraine I and I even couldn't get him
here because because of different things
people here now that my question is it
possible to have interviews a year
because I'm journalist great so I'm
working here
not tonight but sure yes hola I'm sorry
Brenda Trejo ami Slava Sunday Mexico so
Chicana and in my party porque usted
hijo I want to hear your voice so I just
want to tell you a little bit about
something that I'm passionate about as a
Latina which is the environment and I
think a lot of Latinos are very
passionate about that as well and my
question is well how do you see the
Latino the Latino voice impacting
environmental policies addressing
climate change would something that
disproportionately affects the Latino
community here and also where our
countries of origin may be okay Lepus
and now as i quattron is given maryland
if in any level una vista television e
TV isn't owned since pokemon pasaba
Univision encanta como you deliver the
news
londo me estado a siento que Tamaulipas
es muy Vedado en las noticias mexicanas
uranyl entiendo porque si es el estado
de donde más a quest rose yes new narco
estado que es peor que sería KO Pina
sobre el govern or Yoga torque onto
cainy siquiera fue elegida por el pueblo
sino que fue impuestos porque mataró nos
hermano de pena nieto once in cuenta
cuatro mil Muertos imagine LT Seim
cuenta cuatro mil mortis yogi I meant a
light strata general stuff on soon on
decrement cuchara Jesus thank you
two more my question is what advice you
have to advocates and activists who have
a heart for justice but separate
depression just just speak up because
many times you think that you don't have
a voice a strength and you do have a
voice and we need to listen to them if
you don't speak up
we don't listen last well la ultima
palabra thank you so much my name is
Christina I just wanted to ask you a
question about last week Univision
co-hosted the democratic debate and just
before that debate 6 million homes
narrowly didn't have access to Univision
because of the AT&T u-verse they
couldn't reach a deal with them and
Univision accuse them of redlining and
you know pointed this out as a form of
discrimination that Hispanic Americans
face today not being able to access
diverse culturally relevant content what
would you tell the room about this kind
of discrimination today and this kind of
content that we're just trying to make
it uh that everybody has access but what
we just did at the beginning everybody
who wanted to watch was able to watch
and I just hope that that we can have a
new agreement over there but then
Facebook is fantastic
no that's we have to realize that there
are new forms of communication that we
can all use thank you so much for coming
I really
book TV is on Facebook like us to get
publishing news scheduling updates
behind-the-scenes pictures and videos
author information and to talk directly
with authors during our live programs
facebook.com slash book TV
on Sunday April 3rd book TV is live with
author and publisher of Forbes magazine
Steve Forbes on in-depth our live
monthly call-in show mr. Forbes has
authored many books which focus on
politics and economics in his most
recent book reviving America he argues
for a replacement of the current tax
code and a repeal of the Affordable Care
Act other recent titles include power
ambition glory which compares great
leaders of the ancient world with modern
business leaders and how capitalism will
save us why free people and free markets
are the best answer in today's economy
in 2014 mr Forbes appeared on book TV
discussing his book money the topic of
money is very straightforward and simple
even though it's shrouded in a lot of
jargon a lot of equations the the idea
of money is very basic we've gotten away
from it and our policymakers today know
less about money monetary policy than
they did a hundred years ago and since
the early 1970s even though he had
booming decades in the 80s and 90s
overall our growth rates since we went
off the Bretton Woods system the old
gold standard in 1971 the US average
growth rates are less than they were
before 1971 and if we'd maintained the
growth rates that we had for a hundred
and eighty years up to 1971 if we'd
maintained those growth rates after 1971
on average the US economy today would be
50% larger than it is now Steve Forbes
live on book TV's in-depth Sunday April
3rd noon to 3:00 p.m. Eastern
here's a look at some books that are
being published this week in the third
wave Steve Case co-founder of AOL
outlines the future of the Internet
University of Hawaii professor hope
Jaron recalls how she became a scientist
in lab girl in why save the bankers
French economist Thomas Piketty looks at
the European debt crisis and
inequalities within the economy also
being released this week is America's
war for the greater Middle East in which
retired Army colonel Andrew bacevich
provides a history of America's military
for raised in the Middle East
Natalia Holt explores the history and
future of women in science in rise of
the rocket girls and Apollo 11 astronaut
Buzz Aldrin remembers his achievements
and the lessons he's learned along the
way in no dream is too high look for
these titles in bookstores this coming
week and watch for the authors in the
near future on book TV okay if we don't
have enough people go out and find some
welcome to the release of the National
Association of scholars new report my
name is Peter wood I'm president of the
National Association of scholars in 2009
a young man heading for a seaside
vacation in Mexico picked up an
unusually heavy book for his beach
reading an 800-page tome on the life of
an 18th century immigrant 50 pages are
so into the book the story took
possession at the 29 year old
lin-manuel Miranda what emerged from his
reading of Ron
turn-offs 2004 Alexander Hamilton is now
the hottest ticket on Broadway the hip
hop musical Hamilton Broadway play is
widely noted for many things including
its exact fidelity to the historical
facts so each book's did not be light
reading and the right Beach book can
kick up a lot of sand as it happens one
of the top five most assigned common
readings for college freshmen last year
was also a book about the obstacles
overcome by an immigrant it is the
considerably shorter and Rica's journey
by Sonya Nazario which offers a
harrowing account of a 16 year old
Honduran boy a drug user and a thief he
makes his way through Mexico and across
the Texas border at Laredo the Serio's
book contrasts with Charles on several
points one of them is that Enrique's
journey is written at a level
appropriate for 5th graders as gauged by
the independent Lexile rating system
well welcome to the launch of the
National Association of scholars a new
edition of beech books it's our 5th this
edition covers the books assigned by
colleges and universities to their
incoming freshman classes in the summer
of 2014 and 2015 we have a splendid
lineup of speakers to break the
champagne bottle over the bow of each
books number 5
a little later we will hear from
executive director of the NASD foreign
who first conceived of studying common
reading programs as a way to illuminate
what colleges really value she wrote the
first four reports and established the
subject as something that both
professors in the general public takes
seriously we also will hear from the NA
s director of communication David
Randall who wrote this new report dr.
Randall whose PhD from Rutgers is in
history joined the National Association
of scholars only in October first and
his first assignment was to synthesize
our massive collection of data on these
common reading programs into a coherent
analysis he did astonishingly good work
in these last few months we will have
time later on by the way for questions
in conversation but our keynote speaker
is Marc Bouwer line professor of English
at Emory University former director of
research and analysis at the National
Endowment for the Arts and of course
senior editor at first things let me add
how grateful I am that first things is
hosting the launch of this report first
things is one of the true storm walls in
our society against the raging seas of
mediocrity mendacity and meretricious
news to threaten to drown our public
culture the quality books that shape the
minds of the coming generation is
clearly as much a matter of urgent
concern to first things as it is to the
National Association of scholars but
Professor Bower line can explain that
much better than I mark
thank you Peter
thank you all for for coming here it's
it's not happy news to speak about
higher education as an English and
English teacher about some of the
reading choices that are made by the
colleges every year and Wool what I'm
gonna do here is just lay out some of
the background about why colleges even
have these programs at all and actually
to give a little bit of sympathy for the
problems that they're facing when they
do assign these books and what they hope
these these programs which can run all
year long they select a book they have
the incoming students read it it's been
a few weeks on they organize programs
debates they bring some assignments into
the courses that are oriented toward the
book they have the author comes very
important to have any of the author
attend and and speak so it's it's a long
process not just the assignment of a
book for them all to read over the
summer and and they want it to be an
extended experience for the students
they want them to spend some time with
this book why they've got a lot of other
courses to take they graduate from high
school
you got all summer long they've been
admitted to this institution white pylon
this extra this extra reading this has
extra chance the last thing they want to
do actually is in the read books over
there over the summer and we'll see
that's one of the one of the issues so
just briefly there really are I I choose
three major problems the schools faced
today with their incoming students and
this actually it's not so much the hyper
hyper selective institutions at all all
those others certainly but actually it
affects the selects selected
institutions as well one is that they
read one book and this is something
doesn't exist otherwise okay there is no
common reading now either in American
life in general or in the school
curriculum
okay this simply doesn't have it I asked
students in a class if I refer to a book
I teach American literature often Huck
Finn some of them maybe me two or three
out of the out of the twenty students in
the class of Reddit Great Gatsby me a
couple why the most of them actually the
most popular ones these days for high
school reading are to kill a mockingbird
that's that's probably the most popular
novel that is chosen in high school more
than have read that but still you're
only about 20% of the kids it was a
report on this by Sandra Starsky and her
team a few years ago
this is a unique actual condition in
American life of for you know 150 years
in the schools and out of the school as
the Bible was the book everybody knew
the Bible was everywhere it was in
political discourse it was it was in
school reading books in you know the
American Primmer these lessons would
people running around did little versus
everyone read the Bible if you didn't
actively when you heard it read in
church at the dinner table that was the
book that was common to everyone so I
actually have my American literature
students all read portions of Genesis
and and Levay Leviticus which was very
important at the time of the founding
the mosaic laws is is outlined most
clear the air and the Sermon on the
Mount so that when I say the students
President Obama in his first inaugural
use the phrase time to put away childish
things anyone
that can't write so those that's that's
not that's not the Sermon on the Mount
for that that's later so one of the one
of it of it okay I don't wanna say
second all right
but with is over the 20th century
American society the public schools
certainly grew more secular we did have
really fur for a few decades there there
was a fairly common core curriculum in
eleventh or twelfth grades sometimes
earlier grades where you did have a set
of American works that most students did
read you know the short stories and the
Scarlet Letter hauled by Hawthorne some
Walt Whitman and went in a little bit of
Emerson and Huck Finn Gatsby Hemingway
this was fairly solid again for a few
decades was in 50s 60s and 70s and we
know what happened their
multiculturalism came along and killed
that tradition broke it up and the
promise of multiculturalism was that we
would have those works being read but we
have a much richer set of traditions as
well it would have more literature by
women and minority authors and that this
would actually build greater knowledge
and so we would have an african-american
literary tradition the people would know
to go along with other traditions well
that isn't what happened what happened
was that instead of having a bigger
tradition that everyone would read
portions of it became all over the place
teachers are largely allowed to select
or school districts select their own
works Common Core does not have a
required reading list as a recommended
reading list and it is largely ignored
in the implementations of Common Core we
don't want to tell people what to read
that sounds like prescriptive nough
sandwi
want to get get to that because you
start excluding things telling people
what to do and it's gonna be too narrow
and and so on so this leaves us with a
set of students who haven't read a
common book and the problem there is
that if people haven't have if they
don't have some cultural things in
common you can't build a culture out of
them the schools in the report you can
see often talk about community well one
and their right to say one of the ways
in which you have a community is people
have read the same thing they have some
of the same cultural backgrounds so this
is one thing one one problem the lack of
any common reading that the that the
program tries tries to address to
students don't like to read they don't
read very much on their own it's not
just they don't have a common reading
assignment in school or on their own we
might want to talk about Harry Potter
that's the one thing that you can
mention in class that most of the kids
know or but you never know maybe at this
point they may have just seen the movies
okay we're we're beyond we're pretty far
beyond the publication in the in their
lives at this point but they don't read
very much on their own I'm gonna give
you some numbers on this this is from
the 2014 American freshman survey a very
large survey project that's housed at
UCLA it goes back to the mid 60s here
are the rates for those students who
come into college they're first-year
students and these are four-year college
students not two-year college or an
immuno vocational these are four-year
baccalaureate institutions the the rate
of reading for pleasure how often in a
week do you read for pleasure how many
hours do you log that was the question
this is the largest cohort in that's at
thirty one percent answered none right
nearly one-third of them never read for
pleasure and more less than one hour
zero minutes to one hour twenty four
percent one to two hours
22% got that we're out about three
quarters of the students reading as a
negligible activity at best okay so they
just don't read many books on their own
at all assigning the common reading is
to say you're entering a world in which
you have to read books okay college is
going to ramp up the reading requirement
on your own you're not gonna see us see
a teacher every day who's gonna go
through a few pages with you at a time
you're gonna have much more a
self-starter you're gonna be on your own
if you drop out the teacher doesn't care
we're donating soft on so don't even
know in these larger classes there is no
babysitting here no parachute for you so
if you just disappear this is letting
you know you you have to accustom
yourself to going through a 300 page
book 200 page book and spending time
with it you have to immerse you have to
live with this book over time many many
English teachers will say it's getting
harder and harder to assign a book more
than 200 pages students each time this
doesn't fit just doesn't go with the
rhythms of their life you can't read a
few pages and then do this for a while
and then go back and redo it this
doesn't work at the college level so the
one book program tries to get them to be
more bookish okay that's the that's the
that's the intent now some people will
say well they don't read because they
don't have time to read because they are
piling up so many hours of homework here
the American this is problem number
three this is where the American
freshman survey comes in on homework
time and this is what students report
not how many hours of homework they are
assigned how much homework they actually
do and here is studying homework hours
per week and again these are four year
college students less than two hours a
week
29% three to five hours a week